on en sait un peu plus sur le dakar 2009
qui sera organisé en amérique du sud en
janvier prochain son tracé a été a
révélé aujourd'hui
la course partira de buenos ars en
argentine pour un périple de 9000
kilomètres dix des quinze jours de
compétitions se dérouleront en argentine
et 5 au chili
serge bien le dakar découvre de nouveaux
horizons et les dunes du chili n'ont
rien à envier à celle du sart pour cette
nouvelle aventure
rendez-vous à buenos aires le 3 janvier
au programme des festivités 9000
kilomètres de routes de pistes de dunes
des paysages différents de l'afrique
mais tout aussi impressionnant pour voir
vraiment proposé aux concurrents du
dakar 2009 des paysages extrêmement
variés des conditions de course
extrêmement rude
le dakar est orale dakar avec de très
très belles spéciales et chaque jour je
pense qu'ils seront époustouflés par les
les paysages qui vont découvrir
aujourd'hui dans les salons du palais
présidentiel argentin les organisateurs
du dakar des voix le parcours
si les concurrents arriveront à buenos
aires en avion leur véhicule a seront
acheminés par bateau
parti le 3 janvier le rallye traversera
ensuite l'argentine puis le chili
passage par le nord de la patagonie
journée de repos à valparaiso
puis les dunes de copiapo haute comme
des montagnes avant le désert d'atacama
l'un des endroits les plus arides de la
planète l'arrivée est fixée le 18
janvier à buenos aires de quoi gâter des
concurrents frustré cette année par
l'annulation de dernière minute du dakar
ça restera une épreuve très difficile
oui peut tout pas où tout peut arriver
donc elle a toujours autant
d'appréhension par rapport à la
difficulté de l'épreuve donc le mythe
restera la chance
en quittant l'afrique pour l'amérique du
sud le dakar va-t-il perdre son âme
c'est un tournant c'est une époque qui
change peut-être qu'on reviendra en tout
cas c'est un souhait en afrique dans
l'est dans les années à venir ou
ailleurs parce que le continent et
d'autres continents accueille aussi je
dirais deux des grandes étendues avec
des déserts aussi grand que le désert
d'atacama
sous la menace terroriste en mauritanie
l'épreuve créée en 79 par thierry sabine
est victime elle aussi de
délocalisations
le seul moyen peut-être de fêter l'an
prochain son 30e anniversaire